Let's go today to our caller from the two
five zero area code.
Who's calling today from two five zero eight
seven Flemington's Asherman.
I'm calling from Mary.
Calling from Santa Victoria.
Yes.
You know where that is?
Just a couple hours north of Seattle, OK.
A couple hours north of Seattle.
What's going on today?
I should have a quick question for you.
I'm not cricket, as I say, but.
So I think that you're probably aware, too,
that led to the eviction crisis is over pretty
soon here, probably in the next couple of
months, if not the next month.
Yes.
And I was wondering what you think of strategically
withholding rent as a tactic and how do you
think that would pan out in the US or how
effective do you think that would be?
So I've actually I'm glad you're asking this.
I've talked about, you know, I've done a bunch
of segments and there's one in particular
about types of activism where I've said, you
know, calling your representatives is great.
Signing petitions online.
I don't think it really does anything.
But that activism tactics that may get more
attention would be mass rallies in urban centers,
strategic defaults of debt of different kinds,
which could include coordinated nonpayment
of mortgages, coordinated nonpayment of rent,
et cetera.
I think the complexity right now is it wouldn't
just be activism.
Like there's 32 percent of people were unable
to pay their entire mortgage or rent on July
1st.
So what we're talking about is an actual economic
crisis in which a third of the country wasn't
able to fully make their July first payments.
And then adding on top of that, another element
of this happening strategically during a time
when there may be an extended eviction moratorium
or there may not.
It's unclear.
They're talking about it, but it's not clear
a deal is actually going to get done.
So it's extremely speculative.
What what would happen in this particular
case?
The idea for people to understand of saying
nobody pay your mortgages, nobody pay your
rent?
Is that if everybody really did it?
And of course, everybody would never do it.
There's a huge part of society that would
say, I'm fine.
I'm not going to get involved in this.
I'm not going to hurt my credit or whatever.
But if a large enough portion of society withheld
mortgage and rent payments, you would instantly
cripple the financial industry with a massive
liquidity crisis.
It would probably force the government to
have to, in the short term, put in a crazy
amount of money to keep these financial institutions
afloat.
And the idea would be it would bring stakeholders
to the table to actually negotiate some of
the change that people people want.
Now, agreeing on what the change people want
is is a whole other issue.
And Ben brings complexity.
But it's an interesting idea.
I don't know what adding a strategic default
on top of an existing eviction and foreclosure
crisis
would would really do a potential one.
But it's it's a very interesting question.
Yeah, I think, like quickly, like I think
you would you would pan out a lot, whereas
in Canada where there is a little bit more
of a social net for people.
But I think in America, I think where I don't
know if the socialist is quite there.
So this kind of I think the point of view
on it would be a little more positive in certain
places versus other places.
Right.
That's I was asking you how you thought it
would pan out of the U.S.. Yeah.
I really appreciate your son.
I mean, listen, if it happened, if you had
a significantly coordinated mortgage and rent
default in the United States, it would immediately
become a hyper politicized where it would
be attacked by the right as just grifter,
lazy people on the left who don't want to
pay their bills and so on and so forth.
The left would likely hail them as doing something
really good in order to inspire change potentially
at their own economic peril.
And it would become honestly, just like everything
else, where it would become hyper partizan.
And I don't know how far we would get with
it.
Unfortunately.
Yeah, fair enough, I agree with you there.
All right, my friend, thank you for the call.
Very interesting question.
I appreciate it.